they're so proud of themselves
so fat inside is so fat inside disgusted
these days will end
there will be no rules going forward we
got a skarsgard that's all we need
and you know what a reckoning to a
reckoning sounds like wookie leaks you
know it baby welcome back to new rock
stars star wars and or is coming august
31st actually the first two episodes are
supposed to drop on that day and we now
have a complete understanding of who all
the key players are including a new
droid and a new planet making us now
wonder what is the mystery mission that
andrew will initially be working towards
in this first season that will make him
a fully-fledged member of the rebellion
you'll get this rebellion when you fix
this and door as i say no ifs ands
and or buts about it
oh i'm trying to work on that i screwed
it up already once i mean it's tv 14 do
you think we'll see some andor butts on
this scene i hope it's a skarsgard i
hope it's a stella and skarsgard
just full ass the two a's back to back
in the scars guard are each of the
cheeks
that's why you need a double a baby a
double a buttery here in camp skarsgard
stars cards cards cards scarf guard hey
this is wikileaks it's our weekly
reaction to the latest in star wars i'm
here with tommy beck told how you doing
tommy oh i'm excited i'm ready i'm
getting i mean that
we we were lucky enough to see the first
teaser at celebration but i
i love this gritty
in the trenches look at the rebellion
it's no longer i've been saying all week
uh uh x-wing university that luke went
to where everyone was like in college
high-fiving like the uh the uh
post-grad it's like this is the raw
rebellion and we're gonna see it
i i can't wait i'm very excited yeah and
the stakes will feel so high i mean
there's so many new characters on this
show comparing it to like obi-wan kenobi
you can assume a lot of the key players
know people on kenobi were going to make
it out alive so that kind of reduced the
stakes a bit but here i mean other than
andor in mon mothma the rest who knows i
mean uh you know sagar is going to show
up he'll be okay but like sagarrera
brings his own set of sticks again he's
a freaking terrorist but the good kind
of terrorist and he's crazy
so anyone around him in the room might
die at any moment he'd be like strap
this suicide bomb to your chest and walk
into that group of stormtroopers thanks
bye-bye thanks for your help
excellent well those were good thank you
here's my tentacle creature that reads
mines
[Music]
and we are just gonna get a moment alone
in the background
he loves that pork bullet they kiss for
sure he's gonna be this shows the d the
deep what the [ __ ] i'm gonna say
everyone gives the deep a hard time saul
guerrero for sure and
the board call it
they got something going on confirmed
well so this week tommy and i are
talking and or everything we know about
this series and since this last
live-action star wars film really that i
think the fandom still likes is uh rogue
one i think you know we're gonna learn
why a return of this era could be just
what we need so let's dive in
tommy what are we talking uh what are we
thinking this week eric how the babu
frick will and or join the rebellion
baby
that's going to be the question that
this first season answers uh just a
reminder we're going to get two seasons
of this each of them 12 episodes and uh
the first 12 episodes are going to be
this fall starting july or starting
august 31st going through september and
october every wednesday we're going to
be getting a dosa and or so let's
quickly break down everything we know
about this andor series starting august
31st so diego luna is returning us
cassie and andor from rogue one these
are gonna be the main events uh leading
up to rogue one the five years leading
up to that event uh we're going to see
cassian start as a refugee from a clone
wars era conflict turning into a thief
as an adult who starts really as a cynic
to the political efforts of the
rebellion uh but transitions into one of
the most die-hard rebels in this cause
tony gilroy is the showrunner of this
show he took over uh really rogue one
from gareth edwards and by most accounts
even though lucasfilm doesn't really
admit to it fully and that movie ended
up being tony gilroy's movie more than
gareth edwards movie i think at the end
of the day at least when it comes to the
third act which is incred which is
incredible yes it uh the fact that it
was able to be as good as it was despite
the behind the scenes like scramble
ridiculous it's uh it's just a testament
i think to tony gilroy's skills as a
storyteller and vision yeah for sure
yeah uh and garrett edwards i don't want
to knock him he's cur he's
definitely a visual uh a brilliant
artist like some of the sens some of the
shots of the death star being assembled
and and star destroyers uh orbiting them
that was all his his vision the first
scene is incredible in rogue one when uh
uh what's his name but what's the
actor's name ben ben uh
mendo
when he shows up so it's like uh
inglorious bastards it's the star wars
equivalent of the glorious bastard scene
where he's like i know they're there
just show me where everyone is but yeah
for sure for sure yeah so genevieve
o'reilly is returning to senator mon
mothma trying to affect positive change
in a defunct imperial senate while
secretly supporting a rebel insurgency
of course you mentioned stella and scars
got hard playing lutheran an elder
readable commander we we also know fiona
shaw from killing eve and from the harry
potter films is playing marva who's
another elder rebel commander who has a
great line in the trailer that's what a
reckoning sounds like she's so good just
looks crazy and looks amazing can't wait
to see her in these scenes force
whitaker confirmed a return at some
point as sagara the rebel extremist
leader of the partisans now onto the new
characters we don't know as much about
adria our jonah is playing some
unspecified rebel character just based
off of the fact that she's wearing earth
tones in scenes and running
seems like something a rebel would do
there's another rebel character named
vel sartha and we only know that name
because it came on like a toy release
but we see her briefly in the trailer
spying on some storm troopers that are
marching past on this planet with the
the best scar curfew bell uh there's
another insurgent or villager on that
planet named salman pock we got his name
from the closed caption on the trailer
he's kind of telling his son or his
younger brother like oh go warn the
others now onto the baddies anton lesser
we know him quivering from game of
thrones playing an imperial officer just
incredible actor he's just infuriating
to look at because you remember game of
thrones you're like oh that freaking guy
that guy's back he's in this awesome
looking white conference room it just
looks incredible now judging from his
badge of the five blue squares i think
that's the rank of senior captain or
maybe vice admiral you know it's not
exactly clear i know someone in the
comments can be like it totally is clear
but i'm just telling you there's like
they change it someone's going to hammer
you for this
denise galf or golf or gao or goff i
don't know uh she's playing an imperial
officer flanked by the death troopers in
that one shot of the trailer some people
were saying she looks like a younger
ellen degeneres she does it maybe in
that shot the actress does not look like
ellen it could just be an angle come on
i think she is gonna be part of the isb
that's the imperial security bureau kind
of like the internal investigations the
ss what krennic was involved with and
then kyle solar is playing a local
patrolman on that planet named cyril
karn
seems like a bad guy at first because
he's loyal to the empire but it seems
like some of their atrocities may
flip
may turn him and then robert m's from
chernobyl he's playing a character
credited supervisor jones we see him
briefly in the trailer he's wearing the
white imperial labor attire working in
like an engineering department he may be
part of like the forced labor where they
recruit all the scientists like they did
with a galen urso and maybe part of some
other kind of division that's making
some other kind of weaponry i wonder if
he could be uh involved with like
building k2 so or something like that i
think that'd be kind of fun to bring
k2so in yes right now san diego
comic-con is happening and lucasfilm has
a pavilion there and revealed that new
droid that red roving droid that we saw
in the salvage yard in the trailer this
guy's name is
b-2-e-m-o or they call them b-2 or more
simply b
this is a very old and weary ground mech
salvage assist unit that's been towing
scrap for the andor family for years the
droid has a wide array of mechanical
tools and various capabilities to meet
the functions required i wish they
leaned into the emo part of his name i
wish his name was emo and he was like
fallout boys my favorite band
it's like b2 why did you put the bangs
uh over your eyepiece why are we
listening to dashboard confessional b2
because i'm going through something
[Laughter]
we also learned that the name of that
scrap planet is ferrix
f-e-r-r-i-x and this is interesting we
learned from the san diego comic-con
panel that cassian will have to go on a
new mission to an unknown planet named
aldoni
as part of his entry into the growing
rebellion cassian andor must undertake a
dangerous mission on aldani that's what
the placard reads so tommy here's what
i'm now wondering we've had star wars
missions of course to steal the death
star schematics to destroy the super
weapon that sabine had worked on various
other smaller missions we saw in rebels
but what could be this mission in this
series that gains cassian and his entry
to the rebellion that proves himself to
mon mothma to saw herrera to lutheran
into marva and to himself i wonder i
mean because at this point the last of
the clone troopers are kind of gone
right at this point yeah uh rex is still
around that probably the the freeloading
one that i shouldn't say freeloading the
panhandling one that obi-wan runs into
and die you is still around yeah
my because my thought was maybe it's the
deprogramming of the final like
militantly uh
loyal clone troopers and like
somehow able to get them to you know get
on your side or
i don't know i mean because he seems so
jaded
yeah a mission with a bad batch maybe
like a team up with the bad match
because i assume the bad batch are never
going to die they're always alive and
tim is going to play five of them now
he's just gonna be really beefed up for
crushing uh he's gonna be just really uh
quiet and thin for crosshair fine by me
yeah i don't know i'm trying to i mean
like the big weapons are out so i guess
maybe
it would have something to do with bases
or and also whatever it is has to
galvanize him to stop being ambivalent
or cynical right so it's
uh
he's got a witness an atrocity so i'm
wondering if it is some sort of trooper
training facility you know i wonder if
he witnesses children being
indoctrinated into the empire that that
may be the mission agreed yeah i think
you're onto something tommy i think the
more human side of the atrocities that
the empire has committed is uh something
that we haven't explored as much i mean
rebels did to an extent but in live
action we haven't really seen we've seen
like planets being destroyed by the
empire uh we've seen like the weaponry
you know obviously but we haven't seen
the human rights violations we haven't
seen camps uh and that's what's
something that the show is showing us it
looks like we have like a forced labor
camp and i think liberating those
soldiers or liberating those engineers
or scientists is uh is something that
may
uh
be interesting to explore uh saving a
group of kids or something like that uh
uh um of freeing prisoners liberating
just a small planet or a small camp
might make a huge difference for this
character absolutely uh saving people as
a like a a mission that focuses more on
bodies than guns
that's always gonna yeah and i think
that that that seems to that to me is a
justifiable motivation to get him from
going like
oh i don't care i just i'm trying to
stay alive and thrive too like i'm
actively fighting against
the empire now so now an alternate pitch
for this tommy what if this mission is
to convert
k2so this could be the origin story of
their friendship
like how they get to know each other he
goes to like k2 so has some information
he's able to like
maybe he's stuck with k2 so the fact
that he's able to convert it and turn it
into this uh this ally and the rebellion
maybe that is the this first season is
the origin story of their friendship
that would be fine by me i would be 100
on board with that i love kqso he's my
favorite uh droid at least from rogue
one he was my favorite character so uh
yeah he's incredible we didn't get
enough time with with k2 so we totally
did not get enough time with him all
right other major star wars news dropped
this week obviously we're gonna be
talking and or a lot uh especially when
the show comes out in late um i don't
know april i keep saying the wrong month
so i might as well stick with it comes
out in august soon enough
soon enough i can't i can't wait for it
i can't wait for another full trailer
for it but we want to thank better help
for sponsoring this episode tommy is
officiating a wedding this week and
details are still changing luckily is a
therapist a better help to keep him from
feeling out of control
very grateful for better help this week
eric i have to be honest i you know i
signed up i was reluctant to get back
into therapy but boy oh boy is it
keeping me grounded in a time of
absolute chaos in my life so thank you
better help awesome yes see that you got
a true testimonial right here on
wikileaks signing up for better help
takes just a few minutes and by
answering a few questions you are on
your way to getting therapy on your
terms it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional therapy done
securely online available to people
worldwide you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
therapist you can schedule weekly video
or phone session so you don't have to be
on camera if you don't want to and
getting therapy every week is as easy as
a few clicks on your laptop or phone
with therapy it can take a few tries to
find the right fit for you but better
help makes it easy and free to change
your therapists if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
therapy and financial aid is available
and they have a special offer for our
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com wookie with two e's
that's 10 off your first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
wookie all right tommy some uh pretty
important information uh about the
sequel era of the star wars uh franchise
we never really got a lot of questions
answered about rey's parents coming out
of the rise of skywalker there was this
mystery where you know back from the
force awakens we had this flashback of
rey as a kid with uncovered blood
looking up at uh uh this ship this
transport leaving and you assume that
her parents were on this ship uh but we
found out later that was ochi's ship
ochi of bastoon this was the the bounty
hunter that was tasked with tracking
down uh rey's parents we of course rey's
father was a palpatine's clone right so
that was that's kind of what made her
palpatine's granddaughter but i think
the confusing thing was like well we
later found ochia bastoon uh like
drowned in the sands of pasana a
different planet so what really happened
there like did uh ochi track down rey's
parents on jakku but then just like
leave without killing rey like what what
exactly happened well there's this new
book out called shadow of the sith that
explained how we got to persona and gave
us more details about rey's parents uh
so what we learned so this book is set
17 years after return of the jedi 13
years before force awakens and reveals
that rey's parents were named uh dathan
and miramir uh and they actually from
jakku stole ochi's ship
after he had tracked them down so they
were on his ship ochi was not on the
ship when ray was screaming up saying
come back
so they left ray behind assuming that
ochi would uh follow them and not think
to continue looking around jakku for
anyone else ochi managed to track down
rey's parents and uh uh and and there
was like a very important thing that uh
miramir i think is her name did she wore
beads from the planet passana
uh so that led ochoo to the planet of
passana and set it back to jakku and
then when she went to passana then you
know he drowned in the saints and that's
where he was found in the rise of
skywalker um so we in addition to this
of course we learned the names of the
parents and we learn uh why like how
date then came about or death
uh so data was seen as an abomination on
hexagonal among the palpatine clones but
palpatine would not let it be killed
sheave
she soft spot she what a sweetheart so
he was able to make a friend and he was
able to sneak off of hexagonal and
transport ship um he didn't have a name
at this point um you know he's kind of
like a han solo figure he just kind of
asked for a name at a spaceport and then
he decided on
dayton
named named after named after the guy
who helped him they're like i i know a
nathan but i never have met a dathan how
do you feel about that perfect so what
do you think tommy does this make you
feel any better about the uh rey's
parentage backstory in the rise of
skywalker well it makes more sense right
like it kind of shows up why they would
abandon her it was a misdirect right
like it was like their only choice was
to
give a fake trail so that this guy who
is a bounty hunter and you know in star
wars we know body hunters are ruthless
they don't stop until they get what they
want or they die that's basically the
two options they capture or they die so
yeah i mean it does help me kind of
understand the scene where they're
flying away and she's you know
traumatized and then even more so the
the uh her mother wearing mirror mirror
mirror wearing the beads uh is like some
brilliant spycraft almost so
i like that i wish they had fleshed it
out in the movie but i'm glad they
fleshed it out now yeah yeah i think uh
it doesn't make me
uh it doesn't really change my opinion
on the movie that much because i i will
say this isn't like a mystery a long
time mystery i had uh or that i was
curious about from that movie it was
just kind of like yet another
confusing plot decision from that movie
that i just kind of had to kind of like
distance myself from and just focus on
the things about the sequels that i like
yeah just take it just accept just be
like all right but i uh i do appreciate
that they filled in this backstory and
it makes ochie best dune less of a ochi
of buffoon because see like it's just
bounty hunters
end up doing uh good work and they just
got fooled by uh
buy some beads everybody slips up once
in a while even omar the king of
baltimore's drug game slipped up once
and it cost him his life that's right if
you take one thing from this episode
remember omar slipped up one time and it
cost him everything uh well we will
leave it there for this episode of
wookie leaks i cannot wait for andor
and or oh god i mean there's gonna be so
much that we talk about in september
there's me like four different shows
that we're covering
will be the seahawk and or oh my god the
house of the dragon rings of power so
much so much so uh but this one i'm very
excited for and tommy i wanted to ask
you of those four shows yes you want to
rank your excitement level for each one
so she-hulk andor rings of power and
house of the dragon i feel like it goes
based on my intelligence like lord of
the rings is last just because it's too
hard to read
and then
uh
i think it's probably
andorra is top for me just because
i i really am excited to see this
other look at the rebellion that we
haven't seen before more fleshed out you
know kind of probably
difficult hard to get through like
a lot of people dying in the name of the
rebellion
and then she-hulk is gonna be a lot of
fun so that'll be too and house of the
dragon i hope pleasantly surprises me
that's that's my my hope for it i hope
i'm blown away by it so i'm gonna put it
three and like i said lord of the rings
don't be so wordy tolkien what were you
thinking
second breakfast
i mean look tolkien tolkien didn't write
the the era that they're now exploring
they're kind of like filling in the gaps
between the first stage and the third
age yeah they're just they're just
they're just winging it i like that i
wish i had gotten involved i'd have been
like a spaceship lance i mean they wish
that they could be adapting the
similarity and tommy but they just
couldn't get the rights away from the
tolkien estate that's the reality of it
i'm i'm too busy doing that in
claymation but like if i had tolkien i'd
be like frodo beggins looks up at the
sky a ship breaches the atmosphere
shaped like a disc with a small
indentation in the front it is the
millennium falcon
han solo and frodo embrace the khaleesi
is also there that's how i would do it i
think i think my excitement ranking goes
number one house of the dragon um
because i think fire and blood is like
the exact story reset we need for the
game of thrones universe yes uh i do
agree with that yeah that recent trailer
got me super excited i think the cast is
great incredible it's really good the
money they're spending on it the vfx on
the dragons look incredible like i'm
super pumped for this show i think it's
gonna be great um and they got like the
best of the team they got miguel
sapochnick they they got uh ramin jawadi
they got like the best people from game
of thrones to work on this one yeah
just just all all the good stuff none of
the gristle yeah so i think it goes
house of the dragon and then andor for
me i mean andor i'm just super super
excited for uh and then probably
she-hulk uh i think she-hulk's gonna be
a lot of fun i think it's gonna be
really goofy it's just it's just in
general these uh the mcu disney plus
shows they've all been really fun vibes
overall but the stakes of them just like
it's so hard to know how much bearing
this is gonna have on the future of the
mcu so they're really in some time some
of these episodes it feels like they're
stretching themselves thin
um and so that's i think i'm still going
to enjoy it and she-hulk is being so
heavily marketed as comedic that you're
like are they trying to warn us that
there's not going to be a lot of like
movement in the mcu from this show maybe
maybe to me the the tone is more like
hey this is like allie mcbeal and i'm
someone i loved allie mcbeal oh iron man
my friends was an alan mcbeal that was
part of robert downey jr's comeback tour
with allie mcbeal without ellen mcbeal
we wouldn't have iron man in the mcu
probably my friends or we'd have iron
man but we wouldn't have tony uh robert
downey jr we owe we owe callista
flockhart everything we do we do uh uh
uh jane kakowski oh my god wait not jake
kelsey who are you guys yeah from
jennifer
she was always singing there was um
greg german was on there peter was
nickels the whole game yeah i mean it's
a it's a dvd kelly jam and uh we should
all go back and re-watch ally mcbeal it
was a ton of fun we're going to be
covering we're going to be talking
mcbeal next week
counting down our 25 favorite episodes
yeah the beale deal
deal do you bill the way that i feel i
mean if mcbeal street could talk she'd
talk a lot about cgi dancing babies oh
yes
that was a big part of the show
baby we're right in my my wheelhouse
right now and then uh i'll probably rank
uh rings of power at the bottom bottom
hoping rings of power surprises me i'm
look i'm super excited i broke down that
trailer too and there's so much in that
show that i'm really excited to explore
i just
right now i don't care about the hard
foots like i i wish that the harford's
they seem to be such a big part of that
show and i just think that
i'm just not that excited for them uh
i'm super excited for like elrond for
the numenoreans for uh galatrial like uh
visiting kaza doom seems really cool
whoever this meteor man is probably
sauron i'm i'm super excited for all
that [ __ ] i just
i feel like we're going to get like six
episodes of the heartless and i'm just
like god you're gonna go deep in the
heart but it can't to be dense with hard
foots it's just like look i'm rereading
fellowship right now and i love hobbit
lore i understand why peter jackson
spent so much time in hobbiton in the
shire because hobbits
rock they're so funny i love hobbits
hobbit culture rules i don't care about
the genealogical ancestors of the
hobbits i have to agree with you yeah
well hey uh we'll see i think all i
think we should do a check in every week
just to see which uh which of these
shows had the best episode of that week
because i think it's going to change
weeks a week well yeah let's keep the
list fluid
maybe things will rise it'll be like a
heat index we're like what's coming in
hot
yeah i used to do this with uh
with like when thursdays on nbc had like
you had the office yeah community sparks
you had 30 rock and parks and rec i
would like with my friends say which one
had the best episode yeah we could watch
all four and we'd have to see which one
had the best so yeah well it'll be a fun
look we have lots of content we're
covering all the ones i don't think
norox has ever tried to do this much an
embarrassment of riches yes yeah
thank you so much for joining us on this
episode of wikileaks be sure to follow
me of us follow tommy at tommy bechtold
follow new rockstars subscribe to
wikileaks wherever your podcast thank
you so much for watching
you